Les amis, bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo, attention regarder ce qu'il va se passer
c'est incroyable, Clément qui s'amuse avec le fond vert.  BRAVO !  ON APPLAUDIT ! BRAVO !
Nous allons aujourd'hui jouer à VR CHAT car ça fait un bon moment qu'on y a pas jouer
On avait fait deux vidéos dessus il y a 7 mois, vous connaissez très bien
Ce qui me soûle avec ces vidéos, je vous le dis, en toute transparence, c'est que c'est très hasardeux
Soit c'est génial, soit il ne se passe rien et les gens sont un peu coincés
Alors aujourd'hui de quel côté allons nous nous trouver ?
Allons voir ensemble !
Aller c'est partis !
Avatar.. Hop.. Ça c'est moi dans une autre vie, ça me va
WAOUUUH ! YES !
Eh je suis un peu excité, ça fait longtemps !
( Ayant la tête dans un casque de réalité virtuelle je n'ai pas vu ce petit encadré de m*rde sur le game play )
( Vous allez donc vous le taper pendant 3 minutes, je m'excuse, pardon )
Hey, Salut !
OOH
HAHAAA ( * ORGASME )
Mais elle me nourrie, je n'ai rien demandé ! On me rassasie !
Les gens sont donc au courant de ma faible corpulence ?
Merci pour la nourriture, c'est très gentil
Ouais, ouais, ne touche pas mes muscles comme ça
J'ai travaillé très dur pour avoir ces muscles. C'est impressionant
EEH y'a un mec qui fait du beat box !
*rire*
Woah mec mais c'est quoi ce joueur ? Tout le monde se ramène en masse pour le voir !
Woaah les mecs sont dans leur mooonde
Oh y'a un murder mec ! Trop bien y'a un mode murder comme sur garry's mod mais dans VR chat ! C'est fou mec !
OK c'est parti
P*tain fait ch*er on est pas murder
j'adore le fromage
ooh au p*tain mec c'est nous, je vais tous les dézinguer
hahah je suis pas doué
oh mec je veux plus jamais être le murder
c'est incroyable
It's not me, I was the last...
WHAT THE FUCK
noooooo
hum hum
oh non !!
ooooooh
Shit
WHAT THE FUCK !!!
*musique*
whouuu !
oh !
oh yes , ok perfect
yes yes
stop , stop
*coup de feux*
waw waw ok ,ok
ok on tente un nouveaux monde qui s’appelle " I wish  I have ever have
on s'en fou du nom quoi en gros
ok en gros, les règles sont simple
y'a un mec qui dit; "es que je n'ai jamais vu un film en 3D
si tu as déjà vu un film en 3D, tu bouge pas
et si t'en a pas vu un , tu t'avance
allez on va tester ces gens
God dame it ! Ces gens sont bizarre, je suis partit
Il me faisaient peur
Oh mec , y'a des uefo Katcher ! Trop bien!
Vous savez c'est les machines a pince, pour attraper des cartons dedans
hey , hello
non mais attend c'est incroyable cette scène
le mec est tout seul, dans son monde et essai d'attraper pour de vrai un truc
Il va y arrivé
et non
et il rage vraiment ! C'est quoi cette scène ! C'est surréaliste !
Mais va dans un game center
Excuser moi vous parler français , ici
??
c'est pas du français ça
aaaaah
oooooh
ohoh
pardon , sorry
oh non, elle dessinait, et je me casse , je me casse pardon
steuplé, le mec il me vole mon stylot, et il efface mon dessin p*tain
oooh, ça a l'air trop bien ça, avec des voitures.C'est quoi ça ?
je veux faire
God dame it
Nooo
AAAAAAAAAAAH
What you've done to meeeee ?!!!!!
Aaah ça file la gerbe
I aaaaaah !!!
aaaaaaaaah
Only sheet !
Oh God dame it !
P*tain ils ont faillit me faire vomir les c*n
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
j'espère que elle vous as plût , si c'est le cas
n’hésitez pas à me filer un sac à vomi, par ce que ça va pas tarder
Et ben VR Chats et toujours une source sûre  de délire
c'est vraiment ouf comme y'a des gens qui, tout les jours se donnent rendez vous
dans le jeux à tels heure et ils se connaissent dans la vrai vie
c'est incroyable, moi j'y joue en mode second degré
juste pour du délire, mais y'a vraiment des gens qui y jouent au premier degré
et c'est impressionnant je trouve
On ce sera bien amusé,
Trop bien l'arrivé du Murder dans le jeux, vraiment excellent
Et puis écouté, en refera peut être une quand j'aurais plus la gerbe
c'est à dire dans un an
oooh , je vous dit à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, portez vous bien
et...
Bruit de vomi